انا انا ساعطيك نموذجا خالد هذه البنايه
التي ستشاهدها الان يحدث فيها الامر الذي
سالت انت عنه الان هنالك اعتقاد بان هنالك
احياء داخل هذه البنايه ساقترب قليلا انا
والزميل المصور
اليات الثقيله في هذا المبنى توقفت عن
العمل خالد لانه يبدو انهم قد سمعوا صوتا
لشخص لا يزال على قيد الحياه تحت هذه
البنايه وبالتالي لذلك توقفت الاليات
الثقيله الان تبدا العمليه الجراحيه يعني
هي تشبه العمليه الجراحيه فعلا من دقتها
لانه هذا الشخص الذي لا يزال على قيد
الحياه انت تحتاج ان تتعامل مع هذا الركام
وهذه الكتل الخرسانيه الكبيره والاسقط
بهدوء وشديد جدا حتى تحافظ على حياته ان
كان لا يزال على قيد الحياه هذه انا ساقطع
يعني ساطلب من الزميل مصور ان يقترب ان
كنت تشاهد هم يعني يتجمعون في نقطه ما حيث
يعني كان هنالك صوت لشخص لا يزال على قيد
الحياه بالتالي
طبعا دائما هنالك امل وكما قلت انت الان
انه طبعا مع مرور زياده عدد الايام او
الساعات منذ بدء الزلزال تقل فرصه يعني
وجود ناجين ولكن لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه
هذا نموذج يحدث امامك الان طبعا دمار هائل
في كل مكان في بنايات كثيره الاسر دائما
من لديه شخص تحت الانقاد دائما لديه امل
بانه لا يزال على قيد الحياه ولكن هناك
فرق متخصصه في حال سمعوا صوتا لشخص من
الناجين تبدا فعلا تتوقف الاليات الثقيله
عن العمل تبدا عمليات بسيطه يدويه كما
تشاهدون لك الان تبدا عمليات يدويه يعني
بالفاس وازاله الانقاض بشكل
بسيط وسهل وتدريجي حتى يصلوا الى هذا
الشخص الذي لا يزال على قيد الحياه هنالك
نعم نقص في اعداد
المتطوعين او العاملين
من فرق الانقاذ لانه الدمار هائل يعني هم
لماذا يعني طلبوا المساعده ويطلبون
المساعده لانه الدمار هائل جدا في كل مكان
هذا المشهد يعني يتكرر في اضنه يتكرر في
كل المدن التي شهدت هذا
وتاثرت بهذا الزلزال وتاثرت بالهزات
الارتداديه التي لا تزال تحدث هنالك طبعا
كمان خالد خوف كبير من هذه الهزات
الارتداديه كما قلت لك وهنالك خوف ان يكون
هنالك زلزال اخر هم الناس خائفون جدا
وبالتالي من يستطيع ان يخلي هذه المنطقه
وليس لديه احد تحت الانقاد قام
بمغادرتها اما انه توجه الى الخيام التي
وفرتها الحكومه التركيه طبعا ولا تتسع
لالاف المواطنين ولكن يعني انعثر على مكان
او ان ينتقل الى مدينه اخرى الى حيث
اقاربه يستطيع ان يبقى عندهم بالامس ليلا
كانت يعني هنالك محاولات لاخراج شاب كان
يعتقد انه لا يعني لا يزال حي ولكنني علمت
ولست متاكده من الخبر علمت بانه للاسف
الشديد يعني فارق الحياه بعد عمليه صبر
كانت استمرت لساعات هنا في مبنى مجاور
لانهم كانوا يستمعون الى صوت كانوا يطلبوا
من هذا الشاب ان يدق او يضرب على شيء في
حال يسمعهم وبالفعل في بدايه الامر كان
يدق ويضرب على اشياء سمعوا صوتها وكان
يجيبهم من خلال الدق ولكن بعد ذلك توقف
هذا الامر ويعني للاسف كان قد فارق الحياه
وبالتالي هذا نموذج امام خالد والسؤال مهم
جدا فعلا انه يعني ماذا سيفعل ستفعل كل
فرق الانقاذ هذه وكل هذه هذا الحشد
بامكانيات مقابل شخص لا يزال تحت الانقاض
لا يريد اي شيء سوى ان يسمعه احد او يخرجه
احد والوقت يمر ويداهم الجميع وليس في
صالح يعني من هم تحت الانقاض ومن يعملون
لانه الامر محزن للغايه